JOANNA SMITH: Hey everybody,
and welcome to the Google+
Platform Office Hours.
Today it's a special
Movember episode.
So why don't we go ahead
and introduce our team.
I'm Joanna Smith, and I'm a
developer programs engineer
here at Google.
JONATHAN BERI: Jonathan
Beri, I'm a developer
advocate for Google+.
GUS CLASS: Gus Class,
and I'm a developer
advocate for Google+.
SILVIANO LUCIANI: Silviano
Luciani, and I'm a developer
programs engineer for Google+.
JOANNA SMITH: I noticed that
before we even started we
already had a question
on the YouTube
page which was, Movember?
Jonathan, what do you think
you can say about it?
JONATHAN BERI: So Movember
is once a year, an annual
fundraiser to raise awareness
for men's health issues;
prostate cancer, testicular
cancer.
And it starts on November 1.
So guys who grow a mustaches,
they shave their face on the
first, and over the course of
the month they groom their mo
for people to ask them exactly
what that's about.
And of course, there's also mo
sisters, who are women who
help support the
cause as well.
And I think last year,
cumulatively, they've raised
over $300 million for
different charities.
JOANNA SMITH: Pretty
cool, pretty cool.
SILVIANO LUCIANI: And there's
couple of cool contributions
that we can show from Google.
So the first one is a video made
from Google Australia.
The movement started in
Melbourne, in Australia, 10
years ago, and this one minute
video is giving a summary of
what happened in 10 years.
GUS CLASS: All right, let's
watch the video.
MALE SPEAKER: For 10 years
it's been good
times and great mo's.
MALE SPEAKER: It's mo time.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey there.
MALE SPEAKER:
[SPEAKING ITALIAN].
MALE SPEAKER: I lost my
grandfather to prostate
cancer, and I'm growing this
mo in memory of him.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm a mo mentor.
MALE SPEAKER: Get involved.
MALE SPEAKER: Grow
yourself a mo.
MALE SPEAKER: It's Metallica.
GUS CLASS: That's
a cool video.
SILVIANO LUCIANI: Pretty
cool, huh?
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
SILVIANO LUCIANI: And another
cool thing is, if you go to
movembergames.com, you can find
four motion sensing games
that will help get your
mustache in shape.
Can we show one?
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
So you said motion sensing?
SILVIANO LUCIANI: Motion
sensing, yeah.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, yeah.
All right, so it looks like
I'm going to have to
authenticate to allow
the camera.
So does anyone know what
this is using for--
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah, it's
actually using an HTML5 API
called getUserMedia.
It's part of a larger
spec called WebRTC.
And it essentially allows you
to get access to the user's
camera and audio, and do
interesting things with it in
JavaScript.
So it's a pretty neat
application of that API.
How you doing, Gus?
SILVIANO LUCIANI:
I'm doing good.
GUS CLASS: Oh, I
got a splendid.
It's really hard to do, and you
can't breathe when you do
it, so you have to practice.
You have to strengthen
that mo.
SILVIANO LUCIANI: So that was
The Lame Mo, and then you have
The Fu Manchu, and next week and
the following week there
will be two other games.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
SILVIANO LUCIANI: Another
thing is, if you go to
us.movember.com you can
find Google networks.
And so you can donate to members
of Google that are
taking part in Movember.
But also on the site you can
find, maybe, your friends, or
anyone else that is taking part
and donate something.
JOANNA SMITH: And it's a
pretty good cause, so
definitely go ahead
and get growing.
It's not too late.
And if you're having a little
trouble, like I am, you can
always check out
freemustache.com to get a
little extra help.
All right, so with all of that,
we're going to go ahead
and begin today's demo, where
we're going to show a console
starter and then a metro style
starter for all of you C# and
.NET people out there.
And as always, as we're doing
this, if you have any
questions feel free to post them
on the Google+ event, or
on the YouTube page, and we will
be monitoring those to
help answer them.
So Gus, why don't you
take it away.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
So Joanna, thanks
for the intro.
So I've been working hard on a
couple C# starters for all the
C# developers out there.
And the first one I'm going to
show is actually a console
based starter, so it's just real
basic command line, built
from the Visual Studio default
command line project.
So if you look at what I'm
running here, when I started
up I've put a break point in.
SILVIANO LUCIANI: Gus, wait.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Can you
zoom out a little bit?
Yeah.
GUS CLASS: Zoom out?
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
GUS CLASS: Are you having
trouble seeing it?
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
GUS CLASS: How about now?
JOANNA SMITH: That's better.
GUS CLASS: OK.
So we're having weird issues
with my screen, but we'll work
through it.
So here's the starter.
And I put a break point on
the authentication step.
SILVIANO LUCIANI: Gus, before
going in details into the
[? OAuth ?], would you like
to give an introduction on
developing console
applications?
GUS CLASS: Sure.
So developing a console
application, you just start
with a generic template
project from
within Visual Studio.
And so when you actually do the
new project dialogue, it
will allow you to select various
types of projects.
And the command line project,
it's one of
those built in templates.
So it's really easy
to start with.
So if you're interested in
exploring this, I'm running
this on a virtual machine, and
the virtual machine has
Windows 8 on it.
And I've installed
Visual Studio
onto my virtual machine.
So if you've interested in
doing this, if you have
Windows already you can go to,
I believe it's msdn.com, and
you can download a
free evaluation
copy of Visual Studio.
Or you can download Visual
Studio Express, which is free
to use as long as you want.
SILVIANO LUCIANI: Thank you.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, no problem.
So here's a project starter.
And what I've done is I've
wrapped a lot of--
there's actually a library
that wraps the Google+
services within C#.
And so what I've done is I've
basically written a wrapper
for the generated classes that
manages the way that all those
classes work.
So here is my starter
project running.
And when I perform an
authentication step, it'll
actually bring up the Google
authentication dialogue within
a new window, assuming
everything is OK.
And so here's my application
named One, and I just had it
gain permissions for my user.
And when I say Allow Access, the
application will return an
access token, which then
is passed to Google's
authentication and C# library.
And then that can be used to
perform authenticated queries.
So I've also implemented search
and activities in
commons list, but this is
probably not as compelling as
anything else out there, because
all it is that the
real gist of this project is
that it's a great and easy way
to get started with Google+ if
you're already using C#, or if
you're interested in
doing it with C#.
So let's close that one out,
and here's another project
that I've been working on.
This is a metro starter.
And so for this metro starter,
what I did was I actually
implemented a number of the API
calls using the C# based
libraries for performing
JSON and REST requests.
JONATHAN BERI: Gus, can you tell
me a little more about
metro style apps?
GUS CLASS: Sure.
So metro style apps is a new
design philosophy that was
introduced with Windows 8.
And there's some pillars
of metro design.
And in short, it's very simple,
very flat UI that's
done in a specific way to be
really easy for users and
developers to create with.
And if developers are following
the metro style
guidelines, then their
applications will be very
consistent with other
applications that exist in the
new Windows 8 ecosystem.
JOANNA SMITH: So one thing is,
is we just got corrected on
the Google+ page.
The new terminology is now
modern UI instead of metro UI.
GUS CLASS: Oh, modern UI, OK.
JOANNA SMITH: But let's say
someone hasn't developed with
the modern UI yet.
How is the best way for them
to get started with that?
GUS CLASS: The Windows Developer
Center has great
getting started documentation,
and they cover everything from
getting Visual Studio up to
writing your first app.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, cool
GUS CLASS: Yeah, that one is
msdn.com/windows/apps.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, awesome.
GUS CLASS: So here's
my starter project.
And what I'm doing
here is I've put
another break point in.
Hopefully you guys
can see this OK.
And so my break point
is reached.
Try moving this over, maybe
you can see it now.
Better, worse?
JOANNA SMITH: It's running off
the edge of the screen, but
that's better.
GUS CLASS: So what you can see
is that I'm caching the
refresh token, and I'm using
this refresh token to
regenerate an access token.
But this is the first time that
I've run the application,
so it's going to use the web
authentication broker to
generate the access token
and the refresh token
on the first run.
So when I run it, it should
bring up the Google sign in
dialogue as set up through,
here we go, right in the
middle, Windows 8.
And then I can just log in.
Let's see.
And after I log in, an
access token will be
returned from the API.
And then that can be used to
perform authenticated calls.
And so what I'm going to be
doing is I'm just going to
allow it to know who
I am on Google+.
So the first time an application
code is generated,
and then this can be used to
generate an access token.
JONATHAN BERI: This access token
can be used for other
Google APIs as well, right, if
you pass in the right scopes?
GUS CLASS: Yes.
So ultimately if there's new
scopes that are added, then
these scopes can be
used for access.
So that's actually the gist
of how this works.
In my demo app I'm doing the
same thing that I did in the
console app, where I'm just
using activities API, as well
as the plus dot MEscope
to retrieve
various data from Google+.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
And things like the fonts and
the grid layout, that all
comes from the modern
UI system?
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
So if you look at the grid that
appears here, this is
what's called a grid view.
And it allows you to use
templates for rendering those
UI elements.
And a number of styles, such as
the animation and the fonts
and stuff are actually pretty
much pre set for you, so that
it's consistent with the
rest of the apps
that are out there.
JONATHAN BERI: Pretty neat.
JOANNA SMITH: That's
pretty cool.
Anyone else have some questions,
or should we start
looking at the public
questions?
JONATHAN BERI: Let's
go to the stream.
JOANNA SMITH: OK.
So some things that we got in
advance; we had a question
from someone named Isabella
in a language that I can't
actually determine.
So I'm going to go ahead and
ask if you wouldn't mind
reposting in either English,
Italian, Spanish, or Klingon.
Those are the languages that
we're qualified to really
understand.
And if you do, we'd love to
answer your question.
And then we got a question from
someone named Edward that
says that they keep getting
an Error Page 500.
But we're going to need more
information, I think, in order
to really get what
your question is.
So the most recent one just came
in a few minutes ago from
the same person, William,
who corrected us on our
terminology.
JONATHAN BERI: Thank
you William.
JOANNA SMITH: He wants to know
if anyone has been pursuing a
social connector for Google+
for use in Outlook 2013.
And I don't think any of us
are really aware of that.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
GUS CLASS: There's nothing that
I'm aware of for a social
connector for Outlook.
JOANNA SMITH: You can always
check our forum, though.
If you want to really see what
other people are up to, that's
probably the best place for
you to connect with other
developers for the
Google+ platform.
And really ask your questions
there, and maybe even find
people to work with.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, and if you have
ideas for ways that we
could be integrating using a
social connector or something,
we'd love to hear about it.
And we'd also love to hear if
you have things that are
missing that are preventing
you from being
able to develop that.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah.
If you ever come across
something that you really
need, a resource that is holding
you up, definitely go
ahead and put that into our
issue tracker from the
developers.googl
e.com/plus/support page, I
think is what it is.
And we'll definitely go through
that and try to get
those to the right people, and
hopefully resolve your problem
as soon as we can.
No other questions yet.
Do you guys have any
questions for Gus?
JONATHAN BERI: So Gus, how easy
would it be to take what
you've done in C# and move
that to the server?
GUS CLASS: Moving to
the server side.
So the work that I've done in C#
with the console starter is
something that could very
easily repurposed into a
server side flow.
The real key piece is
understanding how to use the
service wrapper that is
generated using Google
discovery documents
and so forth.
Once you've figure that out,
then implementing any native
C# connectors to Google
services is going
to be really easy.
So in the case of metro style,
it's slightly different,
because some of the libraries
that are used for that service
generator are actually replaced
with a super set of
that functionality that's
built into metro style.
So for example, parsing JSON and
performing RESTful queries
is much easier in metro than
it was previously.
And so certain libraries have
actually been completely
replaced and pulled from Windows
for these specific
types of apps.
So in order to support that, you
have to actually use the
metro libraries themselves.
And so that's pretty much
what I did in the
case of my demo app.
And so hopefully in the near
term we'll be able to open
source that so other people can
take advantage of the code
that I've already created.
But yes, the client side flow
could pretty easily be applied
to a server side flow.
And that's actually going to be
one of the next things that
I will be looking at.
JONATHAN BERI: So Azure
in the future, maybe?
GUS CLASS: Azure, that's even
further down the line.
Yes, a complete possibility.
JOANNA SMITH: And one thing to
take note of is that the open
source process at Google
does take a little
while to get through.
So if you are looking to get
started with the modern UI in
the very near future, you should
always feel free to ask
your questions in our forum or
on our Google+ page, because
we'd love to help you until we
can actually get this code up
on our site for you to play
with on your own.
So definitely feel free to ask
those questions at any time.
GUS CLASS: Or +mention me
directly, and I'd be happy to
help you if you have a specific
problem that I may
actually have a code solution
for, anything like that.
I'm always listening.
JOANNA SMITH: And you can always
check out Gus's blog
and stalk him there.
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: He has all kinds
of C# .NET knowledge.
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
I've been blogging about
.NET since beta for
Windows 8, I guess.
I don't even know.
JOANNA SMITH: All right.
I'm not noticing any other
questions right now, so I
think we can go ahead and call
this a nice, short and sweet
Google developers live
presentation.
But as always, if you post
questions in the next few days
we'll definitely come back
and take a look at them.
And happy Movember, everybody.
GUS CLASS: Embrace the mo.
Thanks for watching.